okay do you think that it's easier to
date a black woman
than it is someone that's non-black
non-black is almost like that word of
being
why we're not using asian
uh white i feel like i'd say when you're
talking like asian arabs or sorry to cut
you off yeah or east or even southern or
east asians it's more not to do with
them because
the ethnic minorities are in the uk
they're dealing with it's more the
families that you're going to deal with
right so they're governed by certain
cultures or certain religions where it
makes it less likely so it's not more
them because they understand what it's
like to be marginalized and be a
minority group even though we're
different struggles it's enough to draw
likenesses
but
asian families and this is me saying as
asian man a half asian man a lot of
asian families are racist towards blacks
because of the colonial ideas put upon
him right so that does seep through so
you have to deal with that not everyone
is forward thinking
because kevin samuels
rest in power kevin
right
he highlighted in america specifically
for me because he would always talk
about black women black women are this
and
this is what black women do and it would
be it would use statistics right and so
what the p the women that generally
phoned into his show
um tended to have a problem with the
fact that he was talking about black
women
um
however the stuff that he was saying
was backed up with statistics and logic
so
there's a thing have you women heard of
a thing called swirling for black women
do you know how to swirl in it's when
black is when black women say or
divesting
we've had a divesting
right so a lot of black women in america
are saying that they are divesting from
black men and now they are going with
white men
have you heard of that movement there's
a whole movement called that that's the
birth of the house i had a big debate
the other day
women say um you're not done with men
i'm gonna start dating women so that
sorry about it you know what's
interesting i feel like if it was the
reverse
like like it
people would freak out like if if um
black men said that about black women
said that they're gonna go on day out
they're divesting
like wouldn't you think it'd be a
completely different reaction yeah
because the feminist movement is a thing
and you know well i know it's like women
get the women get the power to say
anything we're like
yeah where where men it's like if they
say the same thing yeah however there is
a man on youtube called
forget his thing he goes to thailand
and he's telling all the black men in
america to go and get his high wife
oh yeah you can't i heard they can like
cut clean like they can do the whole
thing like
if you if you can afford it i would tell
them to go too
they're probably much better wives there
what
what is your preference says a man black
why anything um
i
i i like
both i like black and white guys yeah
okay what was your experience dating
between the two day between white and
black
i've only dated black guys
it comes out now
you just told on yourself
the super chats are coming in comments
from black women about dating black guys
yes yeah yeah oh that's interesting yeah
i mean it's mostly not there's only one
time i could think about it that it
happened in person oh my god this girl
was for the streets she was like trying
to like hook up with my boyfriend right
in front it was so weird but but that
was only once like most of it's just
online but yeah we would get like
comments a lot on like pictures and
videos that we would do
would he post you as well yeah and then
like they would they would they were
worse than his comments section i think
than mine to be honest
yeah so what is that black women i feel
like they have what is it
they do have resurrectedness they do
have more energy for the women no i'm
just asking like what is it
no i'm just asking what is that that
that hate or that ill feeling towards
white women with black men what is it
where does it come from well i wouldn't
be in a position to talk about because i
don't feel that way for me i'm just very
open and general about love like
you're you're free you're free
everyone's free to date who they want to
date and i do understand that well i do
recognize that some white women face
like a different struggle when they're
dating black men
but it's not something that i understand
hold on don't
no
lie
your capping is your cabin right now
yeah cause in my head i'm thinking about
this one time i was talking to some
people and they said ah
if he likes dating white women he can
just keep doing it
you don't remember that
ah
damn all right personally i just turned
my head and mind my business today
because like if from someone that's been
in relation racial relationships i don't
really feel like i'm someone to speak on
oh you can't date so and so i have a
problem when it comes to fetishization
of black men
oh what's that
yes
you know like
oh he's got a bbc you know
these conversations do happen like
but
yeah you know things like that i have an
issue with that or when white men
fetishize black women like guys have
said to me white men have said to me oh
you you're so
chocolate coming um
that's what i have an issue with second
question like if a guy said something
because i'm trying to think of like if i
was in your shoes and someone said to me
like vanilla like i wouldn't care
so i'm just curious like why why is that
offensive um it's not offensive but it
happens
oh okay it happens like
there's so much ways that we're
fetishized fetishized like i never sorry
i never understand what fetishize means
that's that's more my question it's like
a crave it's not really like you want to
be with this person it's just that oh we
have these ideas about them like for
example when i went to so it's like
stereotyping almost stereotyping but
just hearing things about the person not
actually wanting to be with them because
you love them it's because you've heard
these different ideas about them so when
i was in spain oh i see okay when i was
in spain so what you're trying to say is
that they they think black men have got
a big well let me see
i was in spain and there was this white
man that followed me continuously like
he was at a festival he would be he
would be
festival the beach constantly following
me asking me if i could sleep with him
and then i never realized until my
cousins was like it's that idea that
they have some men have there that black
women are easy and they're easy to sleep
with so
but however in europe there's a lot of
um
black women that come from
africa and become prostitutes when i was
in port portugal i saw the same thing
yeah and i'm not one of them right but
that's probably that could be one of the
reasons why they're following you around
they probably thought you were a
prostitute
i'm just saying absolutely
oh you're you acting like you were
enjoying the attention i wasn't enjoying
the attention i just said it was an
issue
okay sustain facts okay thanks
when it comes to um because piggybacking
off the back of that right so when it
comes to like do you think black men are
more desired
than other men